this is still one of the weirdest
running back statlines of all time in
2004 Jerome Bettis rushed five times for
just one rushing yard which doesn't seem
weird at all but he also ran for three
touchdowns Yes you heard that correctly
three touchdowns on one yard so how did
he pull that off it was 2004 week one of
the NFL season and the Steelers were
playing the Raiders Bettis was a backup
running back for the Steelers at the
time who was mostly used in goal line
situations he got three Touches at the
one yard line and scored on all three
which gave them three total yards the
other two touches one of them was a gain
for zero yards and the last one he was
tackled two yards behind the line of
scrimmage leading his total rushing to
be just one single yard despite scoring
three touchdowns